I want you to pick five drag terms that
our audience might not be familiar with
and define them for us I'm a I love the
term gag mm-hmm and everyone's like why
are you gagging why are you gagging so
I'm just cuz it's so whatever you're
doing it's so fierce but I'm literally
in controllably gagging so for example
I'm gagging over this look yeah you do
that which goes on just sickening which
people are like oh that's sickening
can't be a good thing sickening is
sickening sickening is an amazing thing
guys sickening means that it's so sick
that you have to gag because it's so
fierce it all comes back to one another
I'm all you know what I mean Katy is
when you're like you're deliberately
being a [ __ ]
you're throwing shade you're like don't
you like that for me I won't give an
example but you know when you're being
shady and it's when you're acting
purposefully vengeful so what's the
difference between shade and teeth teeth
just feeling the truth seems like girls
let me let you know about yourself and
that's all fatigue so when they say no
tea no shade that's like oh don't worry
it you know I'm not trying to offend you
but really deep down they're being Shady
okay when a [ __ ] tells you no tea no
shade she'd been shaving
hey what's up you guys thanks for
watching ET on YouTube for more great
videos be sure subscribe to our Channel
you